deuxième série d'essais de la journée 20
minutes supplémentaires pour reconnaître
le circuit donné les bois et procéder
aux réglages optimums du kart 15 ans que
maxime léger pratique ce sport en loisir
tout d'abord puis en compétition depuis
deux ans maintenant un virage pris grâce
à une rencontre celle avec la escales
val de loire en touraine ce club de
cartes dont le manceau de 25 ans est
désormais titulaire la sk a repéré le
jeune pilote et lui a donné sa chance
le karting en entier j'ai fait les frais
en plus les déplacements les pièces à
changer deux ans exactement car il n'a
fallu que deux saisons à maxime pour se
hisser au sommet du handikart le mois
dernier le licencié de l'ice qu'à val de
loire a remporté le championnat de
france du karting handicapés une rage de
vaincre que le champion attribue à la
maladie de sa main gauche
j'ai une force en moi qui est différente
d'une personne valide je pense parce
qu'il faut que je me batte tous les
jours et elle regarder personne faux-pas
faut pas s'y fier faut rester soi même
et cette force dans le paddock aux
petits soins avec le kart patrick et
thierry patrick c'est le papa de maxime
une chemise à la mécanique pour épauler
lepisto qui réduit et mécanicien depuis
plus de 30 ans aujourd'hui il est l'un
des piliers de la escales le club
tourangeau devait juste fournir le kart
mais thierry s'est pris au jeu
celui qui connaît pas dans le karting
baïla peu pour mais quoi donc on l'aider
à régler son châssis et puis maintenant
je le suis coincé c'est plus une affaire
d'amitié maintenant qu'est scellier
après quoi sur ce même circuit
dans moins d'un mois maxime sera au
départ du trophée international
handikart avec toujours cette même
volonté se surpasser